you guys remember the try guys oh my god
where they had the
the below like two standard deviations
of t levels so i
i i tried finding uh so for those aren't
familiar
and now that we you know we've talked
about china and masculinity
china wants to make their men more
masculine in the u.s you know like luke
mentioned testosterone levels are down
sperm counts are down reproduction is
going down
and there's there's a group of guys that
were on buzzfeed i don't i don't think
they're there anymore they were called
the try guys
so they decided to do a segment where
they test their tested their
testosterone levels
and their testosterone levels were that
of
seniors senior citizens that are like
pre-pubescent boys or something
or girls or girls yeah yeah i don't know
of women yeah
it was really bad so so i actually have
this uh this article i couldn't find a
good article talking about the results
because
the original video they did just said
hey look we got our testosterone tested
how fun
but then a lot of people realized whoa
these guys have dangerously low levels
of testosterone
so i found a website called the four
second hard on
and they say buzzfeed's try guys have
dangerously low testosterone this from
december 2017.
they say the buzzfeed tri guys are a
stereotypical group of beta male
millennials that try various weird
things and record their feminine
reactions on youtube i don't think it is
the best article i could find so
forgive the snark if you have the
misfortune to watch any of their content
you probably notice something's a little
off you'd be correct
in one of their antics they tried to
find out who was the most attractive man
one of the things they did was have
blood work done to measure their
testosterone levels
the daily wire reports actually you know
can i just pull the daily wire because
they'd be a little bit less bombastic
so no that's not even there anymore all
right so they say quote
the normal t score for an adult male
ranges from 270 to one
1070 ng slash dl would you know what
that means leah
no ng slash deal sorry with men aged
from 25 to 34
averaging at 617 ng slash dl
so that's nanograms per deciliter
whatever that means just a measurement
all right not one buzzfeed beta male met
the 617 average
rather all of the men tested below the
level of a typical 85 year old male
moreover
three of the four men tested below the
average range the average range
and the male with the highest
testosterone level eugene still had a
relatively low t score
with 363 ng slash dl
why is it like i don't know i don't food
no exercise maybe microplastics i was
reading about how we have this bottle
this bottled water right
no offense to this bottled water company
yeah but there's what is it called like
micro pressed the plastics that mimic
estrogen yeah
inside of them especially if the bottle
is uh you know exposed to heat and cold
and expansion
uh but it's also alcohol it's also mint
it's also
you know uh breads many people don't
even know this mint lowers your
testosterone
i've looked into this trust me i got my
testosterone tested a whole bunch of
times were you good oh
yes i was very happy with my levels i
was like all right i did it the slavic
level starts higher as yeah
i think so i wasn't born in the united
states and i think that also helps
a lot too uh you know i was exposed to a
whole different kind of way of life
your radiation levels are way higher
though yes because of uh
chernobyl which i was actually born very
close to
and afterwards and i was still in my
mom's belly so that could understand my
fraudulent slips
sometimes uh but freud
3d chess here okay all right uh what
what you guys caught me off guard but
also most importantly um
so yes mint alcohol some people even
point to bread a lot of fake food lack
of exercise lack of sleep a lot of
stress
microplastics and and those are only
some of the theories out there of what's
leading to this
there's other beliefs that there's even
more but again
testosterone sperm levels reproduction
levels absolutely low very dangerous no
one wants to talk about it they should
be talking about it because
testosterone is not only key to men's
physical health
not only to your bones not only towards
your muscles not only to your
towards your physical structure but also
your mental health so
if you're lacking in testosterone this
could explain why so many people are out
of it
loopy and crazy and we're having a
mental health crisis because they don't
have the proper
amount of hormones and you need to
manipulate exactly i want to stress
i mean no disrespect to the try guys i'm
just you know i i i mean
sincerely i'm pointing out this is a
serious issue
so in one of the image they show we can
see that the the
the lowest guy ned had had a t-score of
212
and for someone who's 85 to 100 it
should be
376. there is seriously something wrong
i mean
this is a bigger public health crisis
than coronavirus but no one's talking
about it but if
your t levels are below them and 85 year
old men shouldn't you go for like a
screening of some sort to figure
out what's wrong could that be something
more serious has anyone ever i mean if
you go into like a regular checkup this
is not a normal procedure it should be
like when they check everything i have
to make sure like i get it right and i
have to fight them sometimes
i'm like because i get a blood test
every six months just to check out my
levels
just to see how i'm doing on my you know
minerals and nutrients and all this
other vitamin stuff
making sure my body's running you know
well and they're like oh you don't need
it you're fine you're in your third i'm
like no no
no no make it make sure you put it on
there because they just refuse to do it
many times so let me let me show you
this uh i pulled up i just did a quick
google search it's from 2007.
generational decline in testosterone
levels observed trend does not seem to
be attributable to health and lifestyle
changes
they say during the past two decades
testosterone levels in american men have
rapidly declined
this information comes from a long-term
prospective study that evaluated changes
in serum testosterone on a
population-wide basis
the study was published in the journal
of clinical and endocrinology
and metabolism they say the interesting
thing we discovered was
that on average when we measured the
testosterone in the blood of a 60 year
old in 1989
it was higher than that in a different
60 year old measured in 1995
said thomas travison phd of the new
england research institute's watertown
massachusetts
we observe the same phenomenon over a
wide range of ages
they say although testosterone loss is
common as men age it is often associated
with diabetes
abdominal obesity sexual dysfunction
depression
and other adverse conditions the
massachusetts male aging study
was composed of randomly selected men
ages 45 to 79
living in the boston area i'm not going
to go through all of the you know
you know full details on how the study
was done just that for the past couple
of decades now
or i should say decade and a half-ish
we've been seeing that there's some kind
of decline in testosterone among men
not related to lifestyle or what do they
say health and lifestyle
well for diet personally i just did i
just reminded myself because i remember
doing a lot of research about this a few
years ago
but it's also a lot of processed food
flax seeds
vegetable oils along with what i
mentioned before mint alcohol
that do have a very negative effect on
you remember they surprisingly weird
they said you weren't supposed to eat
eggs for a while eggs was bad red meat
and all those things they they move them
back up the the pyramid or the food
pyramid because they have healthy fats
healthy fats but also you guys remember
they used to talk about ancient rome
with the lead and the aqueducts and
stuff and that had an impact on people's
health
and i think if i remember correctly the
lead in their uh
impacted testosterone invasion rome i
mean there may be something going on now
that we don't know about the plastics
whatever
maybe in a thousand years we'll know
high fructose corn syrup maybe no really
maybe at the mainstream food supply in
1989 they're about it's banned in europe
is that true
the interesting europe's just as bad so
the interesting thing about the study
though is they mentioned
1989 to 1995 it's not like these are
different generations it's not like
there's a genetic genetics being passed
down or whatever
89 to 95 yeah yeah that's when high
fructose corn syrup hit the market
well so if you have a 60 year old in
1989 and that's that means you have
the 60 year old at the time was 54. so
maybe there's something about
you know you go back to the 50s and
we've been introducing more and more of
something that's caused
some kind of well also the sugar
industry put out a bunch of pr
and and bribed a bunch of doctors to say
that fats are
really bad for you and if you walk
around the supermarket you see
everything non-fat
low fat and those are the worst for you
and there's been a lot of misinformation
surrounding fat
good fat bad fat that of course was just
totally wiped out with this larger pr
campaign that was launched by the sugar
industry because
if you look at foods now everything has
a ton of
crazy processed sugar in there but very
few things actually have natural fat and
natural fat is also
very key important not only for your
physical health but also your mental
health this could be it i mean it could
be a bunch of guys who are not getting
any fat in their diet maybe they're
vegan
so they're you know no disrespect to
vegans but probably getting a lot more
fiber
a lot more sugar and a lot less protein
and fat i mean have you ever seen a
healthy vegan i mean they generally
don't look healthy i mean that's an
anecdote but i mean
well they've never seen them look great
the truths are pretty healthy but they
supplement
hard adam and nisha they live here in
the house and they know all the secrets
but
that's the thing you have to have like
yeah you have to go the extra mile
too vitamin b deficiency is huge i would
imagine iron deficiency iron
deficiency fat because uh i'm not i'm
not a nutritionist or anything but my
understanding is that
there's like heme iron and non-heme iron
you go fact-check me on this one
but i was reading that when you get iron
from say a steak your body absorbs it
right away but from vegetables it
doesn't unless you have vitamin c
so you eat meat you're getting your iron
you're getting your vitamin b
you're not getting that if you're if
you're on a vegan diet yeah so many
people are deficient
in micronutrients and vitamins and a lot
of the food especially
i believe there was a study done
comparing the the actual nutritional
levels of food and vegetables and fruits
just a couple years ago to now and
that's also declining
and that could be a response because of
factory farming
you want to say something yeah i do
actually have a lot i want to say about
this stuff because i love this kind of
stuff so ian was talking about how
he thinks that the introduction of stuff
like high fructose corn syrup is
might be causing part of the problem i
think that i would probably accredit the
whole
larger problem to the problem of obesity
which i would then attribute to the
problem with our microbiome which is
something that no
almost nobody ever talks about but these
are everything we do these guys
these guys are the try guys are frail
yeah they're they're gone
they're the opposite problems i've taken
probiotics pre prebiotics the last
two three months i have felt yeah so
much it's it's crazy
i took it on a whole nother level i
started getting customized probiotics
and started working and even doing
affiliate sales because i was so happy
with the results that i found
where you literally have to doodoo in a
cup and send it to the laboratory
and they sent you and then they test out
your gut my gut you know
they tell you things about you that you
didn't even know yeah based off your
your gut is unlocked
i'm wondering if maybe there's something
related to
the um the higher crop yield that we've
seen
from crops due to you know you have
people like norman borlaug who's his
famous scientist who figured out how to
get more
wheat out of a typical you know yield or
whatever
to save save people from starvation is a
brilliant guy people consider he's a
great hero and scientist
but there's a concern that there's less
and less nutrients
in the crops we're growing as we grow
more and more and more and make it more
dense
as the carbon dioxide night i would
really need to fact-check this but as
the carbon dioxide levels have increased
on planet earth the plants have been
getting bigger but they haven't been
getting more nutritious it's almost like
they're getting
more obese no they're getting more
carbon in them which is just the basic
building blocks of plant matter
but there's still things like you know
iron or selenium or certain vitamins
that need to be produced but that's not
growing at the same rate as just
the mass of these plants you know let me
let me tell you another story uh
look i'm not gonna pretend to be a bio
engineer or farmer or any kind of you
know
agriculturalist but i was in new zealand
and we were on we were driving from
auckland to wellington and on the way
there we drove through this area
where it looked fairly barren and the
new zealanders i was with told me that
at one point
when settlers came to new zealand they
were having their their sheep graze in
this area
but the sheep all started dropping dead
their their livestock would just die
randomly for no reason no idea why and
then eventually they started testing the
ground and they found there was no
selenium
i think that's what he said i think it's
selenium not a scientist guys
but uh they realized that the animals
weren't getting
a vital nutrient even though they were
eating grass and crops and things they
needed
so that it's possible that we're we're
growing all this food and we're not
putting anything into it
it's just like dry carbs and even
according to
uh you know peak prosperity they were
talking about selenium
being very important for your body to
fight off covet
and a lot of people being deficient in
it i'm actually on this website medical
news today and they recommend foods that
actually increase your testosterone it's
actually a lot of the stuff that i
you know have been taking myself and
they recommend foods like ginger
leafy greens fatty foods fish oil virgin
olive oil
onions and oysters mediterranean diets
yeah
as positive foods to boost your
testosterone
naturally because i know a lot of people
who either go down to mexico or even
through weird doctors here in the united
states decide to do it the artificial
way
and that's why there's a lot of people
on testosterone replacement therapy
and once you're on it you're going to
have to be on it for the rest of your
life i know a lot of people who are
miserable because of it
they're very happy when they initially
take it but it's just like any other
hormone your body stops naturally
producing it so essentially you have to
inject yourself almost like steroids
every every month yeah that's exactly
what it is
uh that's what a lot of fighters are you
know accused of doing that's why they
test a lot of fighters because a lot of
fighters inject themselves with
anabolic steroids extra testosterone to
make sure that they're better fighters
there was even legal testosterone
replacement that joe rogan was talking
about some ufc
fighters using and then just bulking up
being
buffer having huge muscles and being
incredible fighters
which also was banned by the ufc and
other fighting organizations because of
obviously people were abusing it and
taking a whole bunch of it themselves
but
uh i know a lot of people that just you
know they take it artificially
um and uh that's that's becoming more
and more prevalent
among older men that i know let me read
this segment from the four second hard
on
they say they are not freaks they are
the new normal of the buzzfeed trey guys
a very sizable percentage of millennial
men suffer from low testosterone levels
the reasons are pretty well known but
hard to combat modern lifestyle is
sedentary
and the most lucrative jobs in the
modern economy require sitting in front
of a computer under fluorescent lighting
for 10 hours a day
the male body requires routine athletic
activity and exposure
to sunlight and most are not getting it
on top of that processed foods and
chemical pollutants crippling men's
hormone systems
the near universal youth of birth
control pill by women results in the
water supply being tainted with estrogen
hell
male fish in polluted rivers are
actually becoming
female you mean to tell me to turn the
freaking fish
into women that's correct what kind of
website did you find for a second hard
on
popular science hold on
popularscience.com
something in the water is feminizing
male fish are
we next i've heard that the
pharmaceuticals in the water is
devastating well it's not just
pharmaceuticals we have to understand
even even cocaine in parts of the united
kingdom
were found amongst fish because of
people using record numbers
of cocaine and then it being disposed of
in your body through your stool
it going through of course the natural
kind of plants it it never filters
through
and of course it's spreading spreading
everywhere and this is also the same
for uh what's the pill that women take
not to get pregnant uh
birth control birth control yes birth
control so so
there also is a lot of discussion about
the larger effects of birth control
going into the water because
there's no way of filtering it out and
of course this affecting people who
drink the tap water the pellets center
the tap water so i only drink bottled
water
microplastics well so there's a reason i
got a glass bottled water thing i got a
glass bottle here for a reason that's
true
we're in a well system here with like an
insanely good water treatment system
and so i was wondering about you know
contaminants in water and how it's
affecting people
so obviously there's fluoride which uh i
i remember this like decades ago
they would say you know people like alex
jones and luke kowski's of the world
chemical waste byproduct saying don't
ingest fluoride but it's in your
toothpaste so people ingest it no matter
what
it's in your water so no matter what you
do you ingest it but there are a lot of
people saying it's conspiracy theory
it's fine
then i remember i posted something on
myspace like this is back in the day
where i read a study came out this was
back in the in the audience or whatever
you want to call it
about how fluoride does cause problems
and you shouldn't ingest it
even if like the the idea is it helps
your teeth you don't need to drink it
but outside of the floor i think that's
a long-standing complaint people have
some jurisdictions are voting to remove
fluoride from their water you have
uh the other contaminants of
birth control pills so this is something
we've read a lot about
and now we have this this study popular
science bring pointing out
let me read a little bit of this they
say it's one thing to worry about
pollutants in our fresh water supply
it's another to find out that all across
the country male fish swimming in some
of that water are becoming intersex
their male sex organs producing immature
female eggs although the condition
occurs naturally in some species
it shouldn't happen to black bass but a
new study shows that it is
and in numbers far greater than ever
suspected the phenomenon raises serious
concerns about the pollution levels in
our rivers
and could threaten several species say
the nine-year study conducted by the u.s
geological survey
provides the first nationwide count of
intersex fish in the u.s and u.s rivers
overall 44 of the large mouth and
smallmouth bass dissected
turned out to be intersect but at some
sites
91 percent of the mar of the male
largemouth bass were affected
biologist joe ellen hinks team found
intersex males
at 34 of 111 sites in eight out of nine
major river basins
including the columbia the colorado and
the mississippi the southeastern u.s was
hit hardest with intersex bass at every
location sampled along
the apalachicola savannah and pd rivers
now we need to figure out why the
discovery raises some tough questions
scientists don't know whether the
growing number of feminized fish could
hinder reproduction
enough to disturb the rest of the
ecosystem or even drive bass
into extinction even scarier the culprit
is still unknown
the prime suspect our toilets previous
research indicates that wastewater
treatment plants flush
endocrine disruptive compounds edcs
including pharmaceuticals pesticides and
hormones into the rivers
even minuscule amounts of edcs can
trigger powerful hormonal shifts
that deform male fissures reproductive
organs during a seven year study for
instance
scientists added parts per trillion
amounts the levels emitted by treatment
plants
of synthetic estrogen used in birth
control pills to a closed lake
the resulting sex changes collapsed the
entire fish population
was alex jones right about atrazine
turning the freaking frogs gay he wasn't
wrong that's one of the few things he
wasn't right actually no he wasn't right
he admits that too
right he wasn't making that it was it
was altering them i was specifically
talking about the chemicals
he was right about in the the water not
being filled he was talking about that
he was absolutely right he said it was
hyperbole when he said gay he was
actually what he meant was that their
sex organs were changing from male to
female
so yeah intersex with this popular
science article
i think the issue with what he was
talking about was that he cited atrazine
which i believe is a pesticide
and i think they later came out and said
that they don't believe atrocity to have
been the main culprit
in causing some of these these changes
in the frog population
but we have this popular science article
admittedly it's it's from 10 years ago
so there may have been developments or
changes
but we have only a few years ago we're
seeing human males with testosterone
levels that should be alarming look i'm
going to say it again
no disrespect to the dry guys i'm not
trying to be mean but i would just say
if your testosterone level is at 212
and someone who's 85 is at 367. i think
you need to go to a doctor for a full
screening of some sort something might
be wrong
they're victims i mean i feel bad for
them i don't think they did this
purposely i mean it's just
it's just the byproduct of society i
mean i think we're going to wake up one
day in the plot of
what's that movie uh children of men
yeah you're not gonna be able to have
kids anymore i mean i think that's where
we're heading i mean it's like
and no one's gonna see it coming because
we're so focused infertility is on the
rise
in western countries and it's terrifying
the stories that we hear about and also
combined with of course the mainstream
media push telling you you don't need
children right
children are bad cultural i have
children when you could have a video
game and there's even advertisements i
believe in the united kingdom that were
saying choose
and it was a condom and a video game and
a baby
and it's like are you are you kidding me
like like why is there such a weird push
why is there such
conversations like this happening in
other countries like poland and hungary
they're like hey we got to deal with
this somehow
uh what do the georgia guidestones say
um
keep the population of the world at 500
million did you ever see
i'm not hold on i'm not i'm not saying
that you know there's a a cabal
secretly you know stopping people from
having kids but i do think it's fair to
say that there are a lot of
environmentalists
who flat out say having kids as bad for
the planet thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you